[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und Dunja Hayali
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend das was sich da
gerade auf dem Wattenmeer abspielt hat
alle Elemente für einen umweltkrimi aus
der Feder von Frank Schätzing leider ist
es keine Fiktion sondern Realität in der
Nacht ist auf einem Auto Frachter ein
Feuer ausgebrochen das kaum zu löschen
ist denn das was da brennt sind unter
anderem
Lithium-Ionen-Batterien von Elektroautos
die sich oftmals auch noch neu
entflammen das Schiff war unterwegs aus
Bremerhaven nach Ägypten ausgebrochen
ist der Großbrand dann 27 km nördlich
der niederländischen Wattenmeerinsel
Ameland sollte das Schiff wirklich
sinken könnte das eine Umweltkatastrophe
auslösen
27 Kilometer das es zu weit um vom
Strand Details zu sehen aber nah genug
um sich Sorgen zu machen auf Ameland
wahrscheinlich wir sind auch aus Neugier
hier gucken was mit dem Schiff passiert
aber wir haben echt Sorgen wegen der
Umwelt ist ja gefährlich die haben Öl
dabei da sind Autos drauf Treibstoffe in
das ist ja eine so schön Urlaubsregion
hier und die die Menschen leben ja auf
dem Tourismus
free mental Highway so heißt der Anlass
für die Sorgen die Küstenwache fliegt
mittags raus da brennt der Frachter
schon einen halben Tag die Hitze an Bord
zu stark für Löschtrupps erst recht für
die Besatzung einige retten sich nachts
mit einem Sprung ins Wasser du musst die
weiche wir haben eine nach dem anderen
rausgeholt sie sind aus den Norma Höhe
gesprungen lassen Sie es mich so sagen
sie sei nicht gut aus
andere rettet der Hubschrauber 22
Besatzungsmitglieder haben nur leichte
Verletzungen ein Mensch verliert in
dieser Nacht sein Leben der Brandherd
ist genau dort wo Elektroautos standen
25 Stück schon ihre Akkus sind nicht
leicht zu löschen dazu kommt die
Bauweise des Frachters
die Autotransporter kann man sich
vorstellen wie ein großer Schuhkarton
die sind also offen von vorne bis 18 von
Backbord nach Steuerbord und wenn es auf
so einem Deck brennt gibt es also keine
baulichen Barrieren die jetzt das Feuer
oder auch die Idee die Wärmeübertragung
aufhalten
Spezialschiffe auch aus Deutschland
kühlen die Bordwände gerade so dass die
Hülle nicht reißt dass das Schiff nicht
singt auf den Inseln erinnert sie das an
diesen Sturm 2019 ein Frachter verliert
Container Plastik an den Stränden und
auch diesmal fordern die Insel
Bürgermeister die Schiffe müssen weiter
raus
mit der Zunahme des Schiffsverkehrs im
Norden von uns steigt doch das Risiko
für unsere Inseln mehr wir müssen noch
mehr tun um die Risiken zu vermindern
da spricht Ameland wohl für viele
Nordseeinseln Welthandel neben
Weltnaturerbe eine heikle Nachbarschaft
und in den Niederlanden nahe der
Unglückstelle ist für uns Isabel
Schäfers schönen guten Abend du
beobachtest ja diese Rettungsaktion
schon den ganzen Tag gibt es den
mittlerweile Entwarnung
nein Entwarnung gibt es nicht hier die
27 Kilometer hinter mir brennt der
Frachter weiterhin und die Löscharbeiten
die auch heute Nacht weitergehen werden
die gestalten sich weiter als sehr
schwierig das liegt vor allem daran dass
der Frachter so heiß ist dass niemand an
Bord gehen kann und von außen sind die
Löscharbeiten so heikel weil der das
Schiff bereits in Schieflage ist und
wenn man zu viel Wasser an die falschen
Stellen bringt dann ist hier die Sorge
dass es Kentern könnte deshalb
konzentriert man sich eben derzeit
darauf das Schiff zu kühlen und ähm dann
das Schiff weiter abzukühlen und was man
aber bereits geschafft hat ist durch ein
anderes Schiff in diesen Frachter hier
so zu fixieren dass er nicht weiter
abdriften kann und man hat auch ein
anderes Spezialschiff hier vor Ort
gebracht was eingreifen könnte wenn Öl
austreten sollte was man um jeden Preis
hier vermeiden möchte ist dass das
Schiff sinkt und so gibt es jetzt
eigentlich zwei Optionen das eine ist
dass man das Schiff doch noch hier
wegschleppt über arme Land aber dafür
müsste das Feuer erst so weit gelöscht
sein dass die Menschen auch an Bord
gehen können und die andere Option die
derzeit fast wahrscheinlich erscheint
ist dass man den Frachter komplett
ausbrennen lässt und das könnte mehrere
Wochen dauern hauptsache nicht die
dritte Option nämlich dass das Schiff
sinkt vielen Dank für die Einschätzung
ja es ist nicht zum ersten Mal das
Elektroautos bzw die Batterien Feuer
fangen ein Problem denn elektromobilität
ist ja auch ein Baustein der
Energiewende ein weiterer ist
Wasserstoff insbesondere grüner
Wasserstoff der flexible Energieträger
ist unverzichtbar für die Energiewende
und eröffnet neue Märkte sagt die
Bundesregierung und preist diesen als
Zitat das Erdöl von morgen an dass er
klimaneutral ist da er ohne fossile
Rohstoffe produziert wird bestreitet
eigentlich niemand aber ob die
Wasserstoff Strategie die das Kabinett
heute beschlossen hat wirklich
funktionieren wird Frank Buchwald
Robert Habeck hatte heute einen seiner
besseren Tage der Wirtschaftsminister am
Nachmittag in Duisburg es geht um grünen
Stahl vor ein paar Wochen noch war habe
ich hier von hunderten Stahlkochern
ausgepfiffen worden heute bringt er
einen dicken Scheck mit fast 2
Milliarden Subventionen aus Brüssel und
aus Berlin eine Strategie für grünen
Wasserstoff
nun sehen wir dass das keine Strategie
ist wo auf irgendwelchen Seiten
irgendwelche Buchstaben stehen sondern
eine reale Baustelle vor Ort mit
Menschen die Helden auf haben und ins
Werk setzen was politisch gewollt ist
und habecks Leitung hatte die
Bundesregierung am Vormittag ihre
wasserstoffstrategie beschlossen das
Projekt betrifft viele Ressorts auch
Verkehr oder Bildungen Forschung der
Vize darf präsidieren Scholz ist im
Urlaub
wir wollen den Klimawandel bekämpfen wir
brauchen aber auch eine
wettbewerbsfähige Wirtschaft in unserem
Land und insofern ist das heute ein
Startschuss weil es schafft
Planungssicherheit grüner Wasserstoff
entsteht aus Ökostrom und Wasser per
Elektrolyse werden Sauerstoff und
Wasserstoff getrennt
CO2-neutral mit erneuerbarer Energie der
Wasserstoff kann dann ins Gasnetz
eingespeist oder verflüssigt werden für
Industrie Schiffs oder Flugverkehr aber
eben auch für Heizungen oder als
Treibstoff
wir brauchen Wasserstoff um insbesondere
unseren Güterverkehr aber auch den
Individualverkehr klimaneutral zu
stellen und deswegen ist das ganz
wichtig dass wir hier strategisch und
auch sehr ehrgeizig vorgehen wenn
wasserstoff verbrennt entsteht kein CO2
sondern einfach Wasserdampf klingt gut
Umweltverbände haben trotzdem Bedenken
der Hype um Wasserstoff als Lösung für
alles ist falsch denn Wasserstoff darf
nur da eingesetzt werden wo die
Elektrifizierung von Produktion nicht
funktioniert und das sind nur ganz
wenige Bereiche Problem zusätzlich zum
grünen wird zunächst auch blauer
Wasserstoff gebraucht statt mit Ökostrom
wird er mit Hilfe von Erdgas erzeugt
keine gute Idee finden Experten blauer
wasserstoff ist nicht emissionsfreie
kann sogar dazu führen dass noch mehr
Umwelt und Klimaschäden auftreten als
wenn man das fossile Erdgas direkt
nutzen würde deswegen raten wir explizit
davon ab wir sollten nur grünen
Wasserstoff fördern andere jedoch wider
ein bisschen grüner Wasserstoff sei das
Ziel der Weg dorthin aber müsse bunt
sein die Industrie brauche auch
Wasserstoff anderer Farben mir geht es
darum diesen Übergang gut verlässlich
und preiswert zu organisieren und dafür
brauchen wir ein Stück mehr Pragmatismus
und ein bisschen mehr Offenheit dann
glaube ich wird das Ganze gelingen
Robert Habeck war am Nachmittag dann
noch in Oberhausen in einer Anlage zur
Elektrolyse sie soll den Wasserstoff
liefern für die Duisburger Stahlwerke
klingt erstmal gut die politische
Diskussion und Wasserstoff aber hat
gerade erst begonnen da kommen dann
wieder andere Tage für den Ministern
also die Regierung hat die neue
wasserstoffstrategie beschlossen aber
andere müssen sie jetzt umsetzen wie
kann das gehen was braucht es dafür dazu
ein Gespräch im heute journal Update mit
Katharina reiche sie ist die Vorsitzende
des nationalen wasserstoffats und sie
haben sie gerade schon im Beitrag kurz
gehört
und wir machen jetzt mal weiter mit
guten Nachrichten Gundula bei dir denn
es wird jetzt erst einmal bis Ende
August kein Streik bei der Bahn geben
der Tarifstreit bei der Bahn ist fast
beigelegt Konzern und die Eisenbahn und
Verkehrsgewerkschaft erkennen den
schlicht der Spruch an und empfehlen die
Annahme die EVG wird ihre Mitglieder
darüber abstimmen lassen bis das
Ergebnis Ende August vorliegt darf nicht
gestreikt werden nach 10 Tagen
Vermittlung haben der frühere
Innenminister Thomas de Maizière und die
arbeitsrechtlerin Heide Pfarr ihr
Ergebnis vorgestellt eine stufenweise
Lohnerhöhung um monatlich insgesamt 410
Euro bei einer Laufzeit von 25 Monaten
in vielen Ländern rund um das Mittelmeer
lassen sich die Waldbrände kaum unter
Kontrolle bringen morgen soll es dort
zwar etwas weniger heiß werden aber
meteorologen haben neue Winde
angekündigt im Südosten von Rhodos sind
weiterhin tausende Helfer im Einsatz um
Häuser vor den Flammen zu retten in
allen betroffenen Regionen zählten die
griechischen Behörden in den vergangenen
zwölf Tagen 600 größere Brände auch in
Süditalien wüten weiterhin Feuer auf
Sizilien sind infolge der Brände drei
ältere Menschen gestorben
in Kroatien kämpfen Feuerwehrleute gegen
einen Waldbrand nahe der Küstenstadt
Dubrovnik die Feuer dort sollen durch
Explosionen von Landminen ausgelöst
worden sein die seit den Balkan Kriegen
im Boden lagen in Portugal ist es den
Feuerwehren gelungen ein Ausbreiten der
Brände nahe der Ferienorte Sintra zu
verhindern und in Algerien konnten die
Brände gelöscht werden denen 34 Menschen
zum Opfer gefallen waren
die NATO verstärkt ihre
überwachungsaktivitäten am Schwarzen
Meer als Folge so Generalsekretär
sollten Berg der russischen Drohungen
gegen die zivile Schifffahrt hintergrund
ist die russische Aufkündigung des
getreideabkommens über die Folgen beriet
der NATO Ukraine Rat auf seiner zweiten
Sitzung dabei forderte Stoltenberg auch
Russland müsse aufhören Nahrungsmittel
als Waffe einzusetzen der russische
Verteidigungsminister Scheu hält sich zu
einem dreitägigen Besuch in Nordkorea
auf offizieller Anlass der 70 jahrestag
der Beendigung des Koreakrieges auch
China entsandte Regierungsvertreter nach
Gesprächen mit seinem Amtskollegen kann
erklärte Scheu Nordkorea und Russland
wollten in Fragen der Verteidigung enger
zusammenarbeiten Russland ist einer der
wenigen Verbündeten des kommunistischen
Landes
wenn man von außen drauf schaut kann man
sich eigentlich nur wundern wie oft
schon wurde gesagt man solle Bürger und
Bürgerinnen bei Entscheidungen vor allem
im ländlichen Raum also da wo fast jeder
jeden kennt mit einbeziehen insbesondere
wenn es um die Unterbringung von
geflüchteten Menschen geht auf Augenhöhe
begegnen erklären aufklären Verständnis
schaffen für Toleranz werden das würde
übrigens auch den geflüchteten helfen
und ist es nicht das was man von
Politikern egal ob auf Bundeslandes oder
kommunalsebene erwarten kann in opal in
Nordwesten Mecklenburg scheint davon so
gut wie nichts passiert zu sein zudem
soll das 500 Seelendorf
250 Menschen aufnehmen am Anfang war gar
die Rede von 400 trotz monatelanger
Proteste wird nun weitergebaut an der
Stadtfeld
Widerstand Protest und Frust machen die
u-pala entlang ihrer Hauptstraße
deutlich hier im angrenzenden
Gewerbegebiet soll das Container dafür
geflüchtete hauptsächlich aus Syrien und
Afghanistan gebaut werden erste Arbeiten
am Boden sind gemacht viele in der
Region fühlen sich übergangen naja wenn
das so einfach mal über die Bürger
hinweg gemacht wird ich dachte irgendwie
wir
hätten noch so ein bisschen was zu sagen
auch es ist es passt einfach nicht ne
kann schon gebaut werden aber nicht so
groß
das denke ich mal außerdem
Widerstand regt sich schon lange im
Ortsteil der 500 Einwohner hat im Januar
hatten Gegner der Flüchtlingsunterkunft
versucht in den Kreistag zu gelangen als
dieser die Unterkunft beschloss auch
rechtsradikale mischten sich unter den
größtenteils friedlichen Protest
die Gemeinde er wirkte vor einigen
Monaten einen Baustopp doch der Landrat
bekam jetzt vom Land eine
Ausnahmegenehmigung für den Bau der
Unterkunft in der konkreten Abwägung war
die Pflichtaufgabe des Landkreises
verfolgte Menschen oft aus
Kriegsgebieten dringend gut
unterzubringen letztlich deutlich
überwiegend
allerdings kleiner als zunächst geplant
statt 400 sollen 250 Asylbewerber ab
September unterkommen derzeit ist ein
Großteil von ihnen bereits in
sportteilen wie dieser in der Hansestadt
Wismar untergebracht die Menschen dort
sind seit über sieben Monaten schon in
den Hallen insofern bin ich da ja sehr
froh dass es jetzt endlich losgeht wie
die Hallen leer bekommen die Menschen
rauskriegen und vor allem auch die
Hallen dann auch wieder den der
eigentlichen Zweck zu geben können die
Gemeinde Upahl hat erneut Widerspruch
gegen den Bau der Flüchtlingsunterkunft
eingelegt will nochmals vor Gericht
ziehen auch Miro Zara lebt in Upahl hier
hat die Kommunalpolitikerin der Grünen
das Künstlerhaus Schloss Plüschow
aufgebaut sie selbst ist vor knapp 40
Jahren aus Prag hergezogen
in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern Leben ganz
viele Menschen die fluchte Hintergrund
haben in ihre Lebensgeschichte viele
sollten sich heute auch daran erinnern
dass ihre Großeltern oder Eltern ja auch
von woanders nach Mecklenburg-Vorpommern
gekommen sind sie befürchtet dass sich
der Widerstand auch noch ausweiten
könnte in diese verfahrensituation wird
der sicherlich noch schwieriger sein in
anderen Städten dann
gemeinschaftsunterkünfte einrichten zu
können für das kommende Wochenende sind
wieder Proteste gegen die
Flüchtlingsunterkunft in opal
angekündigt
tja wir werden denn geflüchtete Menschen
verteilt über den sogenannten
Königsteiner Schlüssel er regelt
bundesweit wie viele Schutzsuchende
jedes Bundesland aufnehmen muss
grundlage sind zu zwei Drittel die
Steuereinnahmen eines jeden Bundeslandes
und zu einem Drittel dessen
Einwohnerzahl so nahmen 2022 das
bevölkerungsreichste Bundesland
Nordrhein-Westfalen rund 21 Prozent der
geflüchteten auf gefolgt von Bayern mit
gut 15 und Baden-Württemberg mit 13%.
die Bundesländer verteilen rund 70
Prozent der Schutzsuchenden in Städte
und deren Umland 30 Prozent der
geflüchteten wurden in ländliche
Regionen untergebracht
sprich also die Bundesländer verteilen
auf Kommunen und Landkreise auch über
Quoten bzw Schlüssel doch wie kann es
sein dass ein Dorf das gerade mal 500
Einwohner hat
250 Plätze für geflüchtete Menschen
schaffen soll fragen dazu jetzt an den
Präsident des Landkreistages Reinhard
Saga der bis vor kurzem selber
cdu-landrat in Schleswig-Holstein war
und zwar 22 Jahre lang einen schönen
guten Abend
guten Abend Frau heute Ali Herr Saga was
wir da jetzt gerade gesehen haben das
wäre ja in etwa so wie wenn Berlin
plötzlich mit seinen 3,6 Millionen
insgesamt 1,8 Millionen geflüchtete
aufnehmen soll das Beispiel mag ein
bisschen hin aber dennoch die Frage wie
kann das sein
ja das ist erstmal ein Ausdruck des
enormen Druck ist der auf die deutschen
Landkreise lastet die
Flüchtlingsproblematik wird von Woche zu
Woche größer wir haben im letzten Jahr
218.000 Ankünfte aus sogenannten
Drittstaaten nach Deutschland gehabt in
den ersten fünf Monaten dieses Jahres
sind schon wieder
125000 Menschen nach Deutschland
eingereist hinzu kommen etwa 1,1
Millionen Menschen aus der Ukraine
aufgrund des fürchterlichen Krieges und
das überfordert die kommunale Ebene wie
ihr Landkreise brauchen dringend auch
mit Hilfe der Bundesregierung die bisher
dafür nicht genügend tut ein eine
Perspektive wann dieser Druck geringer
wird Opal in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern ist
also Ausdruck der schlichten
Möglichkeiten die noch da sind es ist
immer schlecht viele Menschen Gewalt in
einer zentralunterkunft zu haben das
wissen wir deswegen bevorzugen wir
generell die dezentrale Anbringung weil
in zentralen Unterkünften kaum
vernünftige Integrationsmaßnahmen
ausgebracht werden können und von den
Erwerbsmöglichkeiten die nicht da sind
gar nicht zu reden gut und man tut
natürlich den geflüchteten damit auch
kein Gefallen es fehlen dann Kitaplätze
Sprachkurse und vieles vieles mehr die
Landesregierung hat jetzt gesagt sie hat
auch Verständnis für die Kritik sagt
aber auch es geht nicht anders denn es
gibt einfach auch einen Mangel an
Unterbringungsmöglichkeiten wie wäre das
denn alles insgesamt besser zu regeln
also sprich die Verteilung besser zu
regeln
also vor die Verteilung einsetzt
bräuchten wir etwas anderes wir
bräuchten bevor wir in eine europäischen
Lösung Linderung finden bräuchten wir
beispielsweise Frau Halali nationale
ankunftszentren in denen die Menschen
registriert und ihr Asylantrag auch
bearbeitet wird viele Menschen die nach
Deutschland kommen haben ja Objektiv gar
keine Chance als Asylant anerkannt zu
werden und diese Menschen sollten dann
auch nicht auf die Kommunen
weiterverteilt werden das würde
erheblichen Druck von der kommunalen
Ebene nehmen die ja praktisch bei der
Flüchtlingssituation die Hauptlast in
Deutschland trägt und hier tut erkennbar
auch die Bundesregierung zu wenig auch
im Zusammenwirken mit den Ländern die
Verteilung auf die Kommunen an der
Stelle schon zu unterbinden wir haben ja
schon genug mit den Menschen zu tun die
da sind und wenn sich noch anschauen wie
es im personellen aussieht es fehlen
überall Erzieherinnen und Erzieher in
den Kindertagesstätten wir haben zu
wenig Lehrer also Menschen jetzt in
einer großen Anzahl nach Deutschland zu
holen aufzunehmen aber
Integrationsmaßnahmen nicht ausbringen
zu können das ist ja der völlig falsche
Weg und die Menschen in Deutschland
kriegen das auch mit sie sehen das bei
politischen Umfragen die Menschen haben
kein Verständnis dafür jetzt holt man
die Menschen nicht sondern die Menschen
kommen das ist schon noch ein
Unterschied und solche krassen Beispiele
wie jetzt in opal das muss man ja auch
sagen sind eher selten sorgen aber
dennoch für Verdruss klar bei den
Menschen und das spielt dann
insbesondere der AFD in die Hände sie
haben jetzt nach der Äußerung von ihrem
Vorsitzenden Friedrich Merz für einen
pragmatischen Umgang mit der AFD
geworden können Sie in zwei Sätzen ganz
kurz erklären was sie damit meint
also Hauptverwaltungsbeamte das sind
Landräte das sind Bürgermeister die sind
gewählt in Direktwahlen wie jetzt in
Sachsen oder Sachsen-Anhalt als Person
nicht als Partei wenn die da sind muss
man mit ihnen arbeiten das hat keine
kooperationsinhalte zur Folge mit einer
entsprechen
wo ist der Unterschied zwischen
Zusammenarbeit auch keine Kooperation
man muss ja mit denjenigen die da sind
arbeiten weil die Menschen
Problemlösungen wollen auf Ihrer
kommunalen Ebene in ihrem Landkreis
gucken sie wenn eine Kreisstraße gebaut
werden muss oder etwas fürs Krankenhaus
getan werden muss dann muss der
Hauptverwaltungsbeamte das ist in diesem
Falle in Sachsen der Landrat die ist
auch beherzigen muss sagen das ist keine
Zusammenarbeit aber er sagt ein anderer
Schulen Kitas Straßen etc auch ohne die
AFD quasi gebaut werden also es geht
doch darum um Mehrheit genau schaffen
also wo ziehen sie denn da die Grenze
ja also Mehrheiten in den Kreistagen
gibt es ja in der Regel in ganz
Deutschland ohne diese Partei ich will
nur deutlich machen wenn jemand in ein
Amt gewählt wird von den Menschen dann
muss ja auch in der Sache gearbeitet
werden das hat aber nichts damit zu tun
dass man mit einer Partei
zusammenarbeitet die zum Teilen
mindestens als rechtsextreme eingestuft
wird davon halten wir erkennbar nichts
sagt der Präsident des Landkreistages
vielen Dank Herr Saga für das Interview
und für ihre Zeit
sehr gerne
und wir machen jetzt weiter mit einer
Forderung der LINKEN und da geht es um
Löhne Gundula ja fast jeder vierte
Beschäftigte in Deutschland verdient
weniger als 14 Euro brutto die Stunde
das berichtet das Statistische Bundesamt
auf eine Anfrage der Linken gut
23,3% aller und
39,8 Millionen Arbeitsverhältnisse seien
im Niedriglohnbereich DIE LINKE fordert
daraufhin erneut eine Anhebung des
Mindestlohnes von heute 12 auf 14 Euro
an den Finanzmärkten lauerten die
Anleger heute auf die Zinsentscheidung
der US-Notenbank die um 20 Uhr kam um
einen Viertel Prozentpunkte wird der
US-Leitzins angehoben auf nun klar über
fünf Prozent Stefanie berrett an der
Frankfurter Börse Ziel ist ja auch in
den USA die Inflation in den Griff zu
bekommen
ganz genau in den USA ist man ja beim
eindämmen der Inflation schon ein gutes
Stück weiter als in Europa mit drei
Prozent ist sie schon nah am 2% Ziel
deshalb könnte es sich die US-Notenbank
eigentlich gut leisten bei den Zinsen
jetzt auf die Stopptaste zu drücken um
die Wirtschaft nicht mehr allzu stark zu
belasten doch
US-Notenbank-Chef Jerome paul hat sich
heute noch ein Fenster für weitere
Zinserhöhungen offen gelassen er will
einfach die Wirtschaftsdaten der
kommenden Monate noch abwarten und dann
entscheiden aber die Chancen stehen
durchaus gut dass der zinsgipfel jetzt
erreicht ist denn auch die Dynamik der
Kerninflation also den Preisen für
Konsumgüter wohnen und Dienstleistungen
lässt in den USA nach und das gibt
Hoffnung dass eine schwere US-Rezession
ausbleibt und das käme ja dann auch
unsere Wirtschaft so gute und was
bedeutet die fettentscheidung für die
EZB Ratssitzung morgen ja die EZB ist ja
viel später mit den Zinserhöhungen
gestartet doch die Medizin beginnt jetzt
zu wirken die Inflation ist auf dem
Rückzug aber der Kampf gegen die
Teuerung ist noch nicht erledigt solange
sich die Kerninflation mit über 5% zu
hartnäckig hält deshalb gilt ein
weiterer Zinsschritt Morgen als sicher
und dieser wird vermutlich auch nicht
der letzte sein vielen Dank an Stefan
für die Einschätzungen
der US-Schauspieler Kevin Spacey ist in
London vom Vorwurf sexueller Übergriffe
auf mehrere Männer frei gesprochen
worden er hatte die Anschuldigungen
stets zurückgewiesen heute an seinem 64
Geburtstag bekam er recht eine Jury
sprach ihn in allen Anklagepunkten frei
der Oscar-Preisträger reagierte
erleichtert und dankte dem Gericht für
die gründliche Arbeit die Vorwürfe
hatten für Spacey zu einem vorläufigen
Karriereende geführt
bei der Frauenfußball WM in Australien
und Neuseeland stehen die ersten
TeilnehmerInnen der Achtelfinale fest
vorzeitig haben sich Japans
Fußballerinnen qualifiziert mit dem 2:0
Sieg gegen Costa Rica auch das Team aus
Spanien steht im Achtelfinale mit dem
klaren 15:0 gegen Sambia und die
Olympiasiegerinnen aus Kanada konnten
den er sehenden ersten Sieg einfahren
zwei zu eins gegen Irland
viele noch die gewinnzahlen vom Lotto am
Mittwoch sie lauten wie immer ohne
Gewehr sieben 21 23 32 35 45 Superzahl 3
weitere Gewinnzahlen auf Lotto zdf.de
und im ZDF Text auf Seite 557
ich habe ihn dazu gebracht dass er die
Drogen aufgibt aber ich habe es nicht
geschafft dass er die Frauen aufgibt
sagt Jerry Hall über Mick Jagger die
Frau die ganze 23 Jahre an seiner Seite
war und die Musik die hat er
glücklicherweise auch nie aufgegeben 6
Dekaden im Geschäft 25 Studioalben mit
den Stones das ist einfach beeindruckend
und dass der inzwischen Urgroßvater
immer noch über die Bühne rennt wie ein
Löwe der zum ersten Mal in freier
Wildbahn sein Revier erkundet ist bei
seinem Lebensstil wirklich fast schon
ein Wunder wie dieser Glücksfall der
musikalischen Weltgeschichte ja
insgesamt über den scheinbar
unsterblichen Sir Michael Philipp Jagger
der heute 80 Jahre jung wird Jasmin
die vielleicht wichtigste Frage die sich
an Mick Jaggers 80 Geburtstag auftut ist
wie macht er das eigentlich
noch so fit zu sein und den Rock'n'Roll
noch so jung aussehen zu lassen
es gibt ja diese Vorstellung endloser
Sex und drogenorgien Backstage
stattdessen macht er Liegestütze vor dem
Konzert er ist dann immer noch am
trainieren für die zwei Stunden auf der
Bühne und die muss er inzwischen fast
ganz alleine gestalten denn Kies hat
ziemlich schlimme Arthritis in den
händens
es ist ja eine ziemlich wilde Reise
gewesen für Mick Jagger und die Stones
von den frühen Anfängen unter dem Label
Blues Band um überhaupt Auftritte zu
ergattern den cleveren Marketing als Bad
Boys für all jene den die Beatles zu
brav waren
bis zu Ausflügen um mehr populäre
Musikgenre
[Musik]
und Meg als Solo Act aber selbst dann
klang immer noch wie die Rolling Stones
[Musik]
was sie alle einte und die Band wohl
auch zusammenhielt war ein tiefes
Verständnis für Musik
[Musik]
im Falle Jaggers in sofern ein wenig
erstaunlich da er in einem Elternhaus
aufwuchs in dem Sport wichtig war was
Mix Fitness erklärt Musik jedoch weniger
erzählt dessen Bruder Chris
wir waren keine musikalische Familie es
gab kein Klavier Gitarre oder irgendein
Instrument im Haus wir hatten noch nicht
mal einen Plattenspieler und als wir
endlich einen bekam war der ziemlich
simpel aber als Teenager dann entdeckte
er den
rock'n'rollt
we have
auf Jaggers schlanken Schultern lastete
stets viel er ist der Frontmann ein
Sexsymbol der Organisator und
Geschäftsmann der Band danach waren er
und der Rest der Truppe die Gitarren
denn einmal einmotten wollen wird
bereits seit gefühlt 20 Jahren gefragt
das wird bestimmt irgendwann einmal
passieren aber da sind wir noch nicht
ich habe Spaß an dem was ich tue über
das Aufhören denke ich nicht Nein
jeden Tag gesagt wird dass du
fantastisch bist der sexy ist man des
Universums fällt es sehr schwer das
aufzugeben von weitem hat er immer noch
diese unheimliche mädchenhafte wilde und
fast jugendliche Erscheinung nur von
nahm sieht man in seinem Gesicht dass
der Dorian Gray Prozess eingesetzt hat
aber im Moment spricht nichts dagegen
dass sie noch einmal auf Tour gehen
selbst wenn Sie sich auf einen Rollator
Stützen müssten
mit 80 für ein solches Leben scheinbar
ewiger Jugend würde so mancher wohl den
Teufel seine Seele verkaufen
[Musik]
und zum Schluss noch eine traurige
Nachricht die irische Musiklegende
Sinead O'Connor ist tot sie starb im
Alter von 56 Jahren eine Todesursache
wurde nicht genannt den internationalen
Durchbruch feierte sie 1990 mit ihrer
Coverversion des von Prince
geschriebenen Songs nothing compares to
you
[Musik]
ist einfach eins der schönsten aber auch
der traurigsten Liebeslieder ever
und unvergleichlich gut
hinweisen möchten wir Sie noch auf unser
heute journal Update gegen Mitternacht
mit Masern jetzt die Empfehlungen für
das auslandsjournal bei den Kollegen
gibt es seltene Einblicke in das
abgeschottete Land Nordkorea augenzeugen
berichten von hungerfolter und
Hinrichtungen
wir sagen bis morgen tschüss
[Musik]
guten Abend Ventur heißt das tief dass
uns in den nächsten Tagen begleitet und
auch durch diesen Wetterbericht Morgen
bringt es erstmal eine kleine Warmfront
dahinter folgt dann sofort die Kaltfront
das bedeutet für viele von uns doch
recht viel Regen der auch mal länger
anhalten kann heute Nacht setzt dieser
Regen bereits im Westen Deutschlands ein
letzte Regenschauer gibt es noch an den
Küsten von Nord und Ostsee und auch am
Alpenrand zwischendurch aber ist es auch
mal locker bewölkt oder sogar klar die
Temperaturen sinken auf 14 Grad an der
Nordsee und am Niederrhein und bis
sieben Grad am Alpen Rand und morgen
liegen die Höchsttemperaturen am
Oberrhein bei sommerlichen 26 Grad sonst
bleibt es doch meist Kühler mit nur 17
Grad zum Beispiel im Sauerland und 23
Grad rund um Berlin in Brandenburg und
in Ostsachsen im Osten und im Süden
bleibt es morgen noch am längsten
trocken sondern Wolken wechseln sich da
ab der Regen der Nacht wälzt sich aber
weiterhin Richtung Osten und Nordosten
da kannst dann auch mal länger regnen
bei Südwestwind und jetzt schauen wir
uns dieses event-tour noch mal genauer
an denn am Freitag liegt das hier
zwischen Irland und Island und es bringt
auch viel Wind über dem Nordatlantik mit
und es schleust die wolkenpakete über
West- und Mitteleuropa hinweg das
bedeutet für uns weitere Regenschauer
und Gewitter die gibt es sowohl am
Freitag wie auch am Samstag und auch am
Sonntag da wird es in der Mitte dann am
freundlichsten sein guten Abend